the last time we had a webinar which was
about a month ago in March we talked
challenged from low-cost rivals and some
of the reason why this challenge has
become a lot more serious in the last 10
years or so today we're sort of going to
turn the tables a little bit and focus
more on what are the strategies that one
can company can use or a business you
can use to try to beat its low-cost
competitors or at least challenge them
in in their space so before we really
get into looking at the options I think
a good way to frame the discussion is to
go back to some basics and put good
enough or low-cost competition
in in perspective if we think about the
value propositions that we can offer to
our customers they really have three
core elements first of all we can offer
our customers performance value but what
we try to do is we try to win with our
customers by offering superior
functionality innovative features
exceptional quality and if appropriate
fashion or style leadership I think
maybe if I said consumer electronics
maybe 10 years ago the name that would
have come to many of your minds would
have been Sony today if I probably say
consumer electronics and performance
value probably many of you will say
Apple for low perhaps at the moment it's
tottering a little bit on its on its
purchase but the leader in that in that
space so accompany that really if we
talk about for example
environmentally-friendly cause in the
last four or five years probably many of
you would have said Toyota which is
really good a lot of that the whole
Prius has really helped position it is a
leader in performance value in terms of
environmental friendliness so when we
talk about performance value leadership
we want our customers to say they're
always at the leading edge Apple is
creative and constantly stands ahead of
their competitors so that's really
performance value the second way of
competing of course is based on price
value
well what we offer our customers is best
price for a standard offering where it's
more about good enough quality
performance and style so today in in
retailing many people might think of
Walmart is economy but that fits that
sort of bill an example we use from
Europe in the last webinar in that in
the low-cost airline business with
Ryanair which offers substantially lower
prices than any other airline in Europe
and yet provides good enough quality
performance and so on and best on-time
performance few excused canceled price
the lowest amount of lost luggage and so
on and so when a company is playing that
kind of gear what we want our customers
to say you always get a great deal you
can't beat that prices they provide
trouble-free their second service the
third core value proposition so is more
about is about it's about relational
value whenever we offer our customers is
customized treatment tailored offerings
complete and integrated solutions if
appropriate convenient rapid response
and these this kind of relational value
value proposition is almost always
there's very heavily on mutual trust so
they're a good example might be private
banking where what we would one with a
private banker of course as they provide
a very customized solution to our
particular needs and so and what we
would like our customers to say of
course is that it's very much about they
really understand my business issues
they provide exactly what I need I
consider them to be a close business
partner or the companies that might fit
in that in that their relational value
would be certainly since its early
there's a Cisco really focused a lot on
relational value General Electric in
many of its businesses
IBM Global Services would be another one
so that's all about those three core
value propositions now clearly as a
customer what we would like is we want
all three really we want the best
performing products at the lowest
possible price with a nice warm
customized relationship with our
supplier but most of us of course are
realistic enough to realize that we have
to make trade-offs and we have to have
some priorities and of course there's a
company what we tend to do or a business
unit within a company more correctly we
will probably for a particular period of
time we will tend to focus on one of
those value propositions has been the
key focus of our efforts and then more
try to satisfy on from satisfies on the
other ones so if we're playing playing a
performance value game yes we may have
some flexibility in terms of price but I
put there parody that we've got to be in
the ballpark in terms of price we've got
to be in the ballpark at a particular
point in time in terms of relational
value and of course if we want to be the
leader then we have to be well above
parity in for example if we trying to be
a performance value leader well above
the parity in terms of what our
competitors are offering in terms of
performance in terms of performance
value so and of course what we see is
that parity tends to improve all the
time performance in the particular
product or service category tend to get
better over time prices in real terms
tend to fall the relational value tends
to improve often these days mediated by
technology and customer relation
management systems and so on we can help
provide better relational value often at
lower that lower cost now that's a
fairly static view of these core value
propositions if we take a more dynamic
perspective on them then if we take a
look at the introductory stage
a new product life cycle sorry of a new
product that life cycles have a new
product category let's think about
mobile phones and the late 80s or laptop
computers in the late 80s and then in
the early days in the introductory stage
of a product life cycle most customers
are initially very very cold focused on
performance value why well initially
performance often isn't very good for
those of you that can remember back to
the early days of laptop computers or
mobile phones they weren't very very
good initially mobile phones were heavy
they had poor battery life the radio and
aerials weren't very good calls were
dropped frequently the screens were hard
to read and so on and of course over
time they improved so most customers
with it fairly eagerly for the next
generation of the product the next
year's new mobile phone or laptop
computer because there was a significant
improvement in performance of course
they're always going to be a few
customers that even at the introductory
stage are very focused on price and they
will buy a cheap a brick mobile phone if
you like as long as it's cheap enough
and depending of course on the product
category there may be some some
customers that really want somebody that
will provide them a nice tight
relationship will cater to their needs
even though their products may not be
the best in the market space they're all
the time of course as a product category
moves towards maturity goes through the
growth stage and movement towards
maturity
a couple of things start to happen first
of all the performance gets steadily
improves all the time initially the
performance improvements are large and
very noticeable but all the time the
increments get smaller and smaller and
often from from the point of view of the
suppliers the costs of getting these
incremental improvements may arise and
in some businesses may even
eyes exponentially there's still a lot
of improved opportunity often for cost
reduction so price value tends to
improve and of course relational value
also often tends to improve all the time
then what we often see happening is at
some point during this evolution of
performance value some customers perhaps
new customers that have just entered the
market sort of say hey the performance
today is good enough I don't need the
latest and greatest I don't need to wait
for the latest an app or smartphone or
whatever the product category happens to
be what I'm going to look for is
something with good enough performance
at a very good price or if appropriate
somebody that provide has good very good
performing products maybe not the best
but really will work very very closely
with me and will look after my every
need and so what we see over time is we
see the share of the total market that
is goes to companies of products that
are focused on performance leadership
versus price value or relational value
tends to shrink there's nothing in magic
about the size of these different
bubbles but the point is that that
generally over time a smaller percentage
of the overall customers in the market
are looking for reading the absolutely
the latest and greatest performance and
there is a bigger and bigger group that
neither one price value or relational
value again depending a lot on the
particular characteristics of the
product or service category we're
probably starting to see this certainly
move in this direction now on the
smartphone space maybe not so much in
North America or Western Europe but now
it's very very clearly a segment
particularly in emerging markets like
India and China and India
in Latin America where there's a
significant number of customers one day
smartphone but they don't want the
latest and greatest they're happy
getting a very good spot foam or a good
enough smartphone at a reasonable price
so we're probably going to see a lot of
growth in the smartphone business
actually care not at the very dilute the
most leading performance end of the
market but rather good in our products
had very attractive prices we're sort of
seeing this developed very rapidly in
countries like India for example at the
current time so so that's what we're
sort of see and of course this cycle
seems to be happening more and more
quickly in many industries we go from
introduction to grow us to maturity in
very very short periods of time one my
review know for those of you that are
old enough and remember TPS before LCDs
when we had cathode ray tubes and
sorting with a Trinitron technology kept
of performance leadership edge for many
many years in that business but when we
came to LCD technology that industry
very rapidly moved to commoditization in
a very very short period of time so the
price value of the segment of the market
became very big very quickly and even so
the very soon there was a big a large
good enough segment of the market and I
think we're seeing that happen with more
and more speed in many many industries
today so another way of looking at it
right if you like with this diagram sort
of suggests that as we move over time in
the early stages a lot of the a lot of
the big percentage of the overall market
is focused on performance value
performance leadership products but over
time it moves towards price value
relational value and performance value
tends to shrink
of course what we've seen in some
industries in Silicon Valley that a lot
of companies dawn perhaps anticipate
this trend and continue to pee
a performance value grand as that
becomes of interest to fewer a fewer
customers in the market at least a
smaller and smaller percentage of the
customers in the market get in if you
think back over the last couple of
decades to engineering workstations you
know and we saw companies like Silicon
Graphics
who were a very significant player when
it was a performance valued an but
really didn't adjust as the world moved
on and ultimately I think Silicon
Graphics and some other players went
bankrupt or dropped out of the business
so as we we face this commoditization of
the market and more and more customers
start responding to good enough products
that are often provided of course by
low-cost competitors or price value
competitors as a traditional premium
player that perhaps started out
emphasizing performance value we have
really three options for responding to
the lower cost competition third option
of course is to try to respond by moving
into the lower tiers of the market and
challenging the low cost competitors
directly with our own price value or
good enough products and services in
fact an option is just to keep doing
what we've always done is to try to
difference our business from the price
value the low cost competitors by
continue to increase performance volume
and the third option of course is to try
to distance our business from the low
cost competitors by increasing
relational value by building tight and
intimate relationships with our
customers so there's a significant
percentage of the customers in the
market will choose to do business with
us rather than somebody offering good
enough products that's a low price of
course realistically what most of us do
most companies do is use a combination
of these are options so if we've been
playing a performance leadership game
what we might do is we might do continue
to do option 2 plus option 1 or we may
even do
move more towards option three and do
option one as well so there are various
combinations and of course that we can
choose some companies that historically
did not play the price value game have
decided they have to do it aggressively
and most of their businesses a good
example a recent good example becoming
recently been very public about this
sore the strategic direction is taking
his General Electric as in a
conversation Jeff Immelt had with the
Financial Times that he talked about in
the past the General Electric a tend to
produce only quality expensive high-end
products to sell around the world but
that strategy Jeff Immelt said is
changing in nearly every product from
wind turbines to medical scanners now I
want to occupy every corner in industry
I want to have the value product all the
way up to the high end product emilp
said we don't want to get any space to a
competitor from places like China and
India so his fear of course is letting
and he uses China and India as examples
but it certainly doesn't have to just be
there letting a competitor from one of
those countries get established very
very strongly in the good enough
segments of the market and using it that
as a base over time to move up market
into the premium segment of the market
and we talked to us last month about
some examples of that come most
companies like Huawei that have written
from good in our products in the Chinese
market to do now being probably the
world's largest supplier of
telecommunications equipment including
premium products at the very high end or
the highest end of the industry so the
first option then is essentially again
I'm using that I did the triangle that
we used in the in the first webinar is
where we decide to move through into
lower tiers of the market and challenge
those low cost competitors directly
either through organic growth or through
acquisition or we'll come back to that
in a minute
I don't we don't really have time and I
don't want to go into much detail but
there are a lot of arguments that we can
make about why that might be a good idea
first of all in many many businesses
there's a real market need for good
enough products as we talked about
earlier all the time is a growing
proportion of customers in many markets
seek good enough products at low
attractive prices so a second advantage
to inter moving directly into the low
tier of the market of course it gives us
an opportunity to build relationships
with customers customers who today are
buying good enough products but perhaps
either in a business to consumer or
business to business market over time
might seek to buy premium products
getting a good example might be in China
Ravinia whether we're dealing with we're
selling our in a business-to-business
world selling our products to companies
that are competing in the domestic
market in China they're themselves are
making good enough products or services
they are buying good enough maybe
equipment for them and their
manufacturing operations and so on but
perhaps at some point they might decide
to go outside of China into Western
Europe and North America for example and
then they may want to have a product
that meets international standards for
example in in the power generation
business with gensets
for example a Chinese company moving
into Europe or North America might want
to have an engine from Cummins or
caterpillar or somebody like that their
can be serviced anywhere in the world
where spare parts availability in 24
hour service is available so in China
they might have been quite happy buying
a good enough product from a local
supplier but now it's big all global
they want to buy a product that is
service and spare parts availability
around the world so that's what we mean
about building relations
with customers that when they decide to
have a need for a premium product
they've been happy with our getting our
product they look to us for a premium
product the other reason of course is
often it's an opportunity to gain
economies of scale because many of the
parts subsystems in the good enough
product and the premium product might be
shared it also if we have a strong sales
or distribution organization and may
create sell up opportunities customers
are attract to our good enough product
but it's a salesperson might be able to
say for this application you really need
our premium product for this this and
this reason and give some justification
and they buy the premium product because
it helps control the low end competition
because now we're competing with them in
their space rather than waiting for them
to come into the premium market and
challenges in our space and of course in
some businesses we may feel if we don't
go down into the market into the good
enough segments of the market we are
ultimately as the good enough
competitors move up we may be actually
driven out at the top of the market of
course it's not just advantages there
are disadvantages with the potential
cannibalization about hanging high-end
products with perhaps particularly
attractive market margins by a
good-enough product with less with lower
margins but of course the argument
against that is if we don't do it
somebody else will and so the great
margin rigs we are experienced in them
today will be zero margin in the future
of a competitor take that business of
away a promise
it may of course damage the brand image
the good in our products may not be of
the same performance the same quality
levels of our traditional products and
of course some can we deal with that
with a sub branding strategy and of
course another significant disadvantage
is that just we lose focus on our core
business we're now trying to compete in
two very different different markets and
we may perhaps end up with a confused
business model but as we know there are
lots of companies that have made the
some of them very successfully some of
them left successfully a very successful
one with another they talked about all
these example would be Dow Corning which
is the world's largest supplier silicone
which has a sub brand called diameter
which basically is an online business
model it sells a limited range of
products I wrote a crisis for the
customers that are willing to buy in
larger quantities don't require the same
level of service will adhere to very
strict business rules and so on we have
a company like Nestle a b2c example that
today is selling good enough products in
many of the world's emerging markets as
it tries to build a Nestle brand with
customers even in remote rural areas and
villages and so on so they have an
affiliation with Nestle before they move
to the cities where they then will maybe
be thinking about private label brands
from Walmart a Carol or a Tesco or
somebody like that clearly software
companies like Adobe and Intuit have
good enough products that adore the
Photoshop Elements and intuitive basic
versions of it into its quicken
QuickBooks TurboTax would be examples
that and so on there's some examples
there General Electric we talked about
Vestas which is the as been the
performance leader if we would like in
the wind turbine businesses try to and
so successfully try to move into the
Gooding up wind turbine market in China
ABB dan post corny married and so on as
I mentioned some of these companies are
done it through acquisition this is a
comic called Danfoss which makes
frequency converters for applications
like production lines cranes things like
that and it shows to move into the good
enough segments of the market by
acquiring a
low cost the Chinese good enough they're
in a local market in China and then
essentially using a sub branding
strategy and you will be able to see on
this what the boy if you could dig into
this website that this is a business
unit love of Danville's it also today
manufacturers dan post branded products
for the the parent company the company
the chose a different route is a BB in
process automation again this is its
operation in China it's a company called
wind nation and it has tried to build
the Chinese coming organically from
scratch um so just a totally Greenfield
Chinese company in the process
automation business where ABB is the
global if the global market leader and
this has been a very interesting journey
for them a journey that they are still
on and of course if it works for them
this is something likely they will
duplicate in other parts of the ABP
business but there are huge challenges
in both doing the holic the acquisition
of a low-cost competitor and then of
course the greenfield or the organic
route that ABB has taken and a lot of it
is a really around mindset it's real
it's very it's a very different requires
a very different mindset to succeed in a
good enough segment of the market than
it then it does to succeed in the
performance leadership game or even with
the relational value game so those are
those are its couple of examples or some
examples of companies pursuing option
one option two is where we continue to
basically pay the performance leadership
game but what we try to do is distance
our business from low cost competitors
by increasing performance value what we
try to do is develop products and
services that are superior to those of
lower priced competitors in terms of
functionality quality before
which are our style so we talked a bit
about Apple we talked about Toyota Intel
would be an excellent example of the
other company that is trying to to try
to do this in its primary business or
you could say felt Intel is also pursued
option one in its early days with its
super on their processes another good
one would be FML the company that makes
the lithography systems for companies
like Intel and Samsung and tsmc and so
on and of course we have some familiar
examples even in the b2b to see space
Gillette prospered was now part of
Procter & Gamble have been successful in
increasing performance value all the
time you know it started off with truck
2 blades in 1971 with a 2-player razor
and then good news it's disposable -
blade in in 1976 and of course the day
it's got the food fusion and so with
five lids and and so on and one one is
how many blades can you ultimately get
can you keep playing this game but so
far P&G has done this quite successful
in and the razor blade business the
razor Blizz miss continues to be a
profitable one for Procter and Gamble
one of the issues of course is it's
increasingly a challenge to get a good
return on investment by improving
performance value in many industries and
as we talked about we talked about quite
a bit in the webinar in March
competitors copyists so much more
quickly than they did 10 or 20 years ago
and there's a lot of reasons for this
more which we talked about in March so
we make this big investment in R&D but
we find it's very difficult to get a
good return on investment before it's
copied and we're having to slash prices
to to hold on a market share and so on
and to increase performance value in
useful ways really requires a deep an
understanding of customer needs we have
to you think you know really understand
customers to know what will create real
custom
value the customers were willing to pay
a significant premium poll again maybe
20 years ago for in a high-tech business
we try to expect the competitors there
maybe not always certain which things
that we were doing would really actually
provide value to customers which
wouldn't so we just try to expect them
and hope that some of this wood would
stick clearly today there are penalties
in that in terms of cost and time and so
on so we can't afford to do that anymore
so today we have to be really really
focused on only truly increasing
performance value in areas we really
feel that customers will be willing to
pay a premium for and of course
particularly into business to business
market more and more our customers are
looking for products that improve
performance value will lead to improve
financial results from them they say
yeah I sort of agree that you're doing
some really neat things here but show me
how it's going to impact my bottom line
and we are seeing some companies that
are doing a pretty good job of a really
good example of that I think is SKF that
some of you will know is perhaps the
world's largest SKF is the largest
bearing manufacturer in the world making
everything Daring's from tiny little
micro bearings to the bearings on on
massive wind turbines and things of that
sort and clearly SKF historically
compared it competed by producing the
very best bearings in the industry and
charging premium prices for them but
again like many of you its customers are
really asking what have you really done
for me recently that will impact my
bottom line so it has something called
its documented solutions program and
what it's developed over the last 10 15
years as a database containing almost
20,000 case studies of SKF products in
use where end-user investments of
benefits are being identified quantified
measured and tracked each case study
captures the application of the bearing
the benefits the customer received
produced failure aired longer life
savings and labor materia
inventory etc the investments the
customer had to made to get those
benefits for example the premium paid
for the SKF bearings perhaps additional
tools they had to buy or add in services
add-on services they needed such as
condition monitoring services and things
of like that sort but with this database
and a software tool then SKF can
calculate the expected savings in our
ROI for a customer from choosing the SKF
solution over competitive offerings and
certainly each of these twenty thousand
case studies the customer has signed off
on and said yes I use the SKF solution
and these are the benefits are received
this is the value of the benefits are
received and these are the investments I
had to make to get those benefits so the
case studies look something like like
this you know this is an example from a
petrochemical refinery pump population
of over 500 sk are promises that can
reduce their increase the mean time
between failures from 18 months to 54
months so in that fifty four month
period reducing the number of failures
of pumps by a thousand and forty six the
cost of a pair those failures is about
12.5 million in components and about 1.2
million in labor to to fix the pump so
the total cost of the of the failures to
the customer would have been thirteen
point six seven million the investment
in the SKF solution would have been cost
the customer 2.3 million so the net
benefit is eleven point four million
giving and the SKF solution providing
narrow y of five hundred percent so this
kind of data is pretty convincing to
many customers since it's based on
customer customer data signed off
customer data and SKF will even in in
many cases guarantee a portion of the
ROI clearly in this case a wooden
guarantee five hundred percent but it
might guarantee the customer
percent return on investment if they
follow the SKF solution so this is
pretty convincing to many customers and
gives them a good reason to buy the SKF
solution over a much cheaper Chinese
solution now to do this hasn't been an
easy task
getting those twenty thousand case
studies has been a very very big task of
course for SKF to pull those together to
really build the expertise to provide
these solutions it's how to make a whole
series of X of acquisitions over the
last few years it wasn't very good at
making acquisitions initially so it'll
know how to learn how to successfully
integrate acquisitions and so on but
today and many of the business it serves
it really is the expert and customers
value its expertise in many many areas
that goes well beyond just supplying the
bearing the third option of course is to
try and distance our business from low
cost competitive by increasing relation
value here we try to build tight in the
new room intimate relationships with
customers that make the business less
vulnerable to low cost competitors and
put a few examples here one will talk
about its article but Procter & Gamble
in a business-to-business sense this
does it with its customers like Safeway
and Kroger and Walmart and Tesco and so
on GE does in many businesses IBM Global
Services Cisco
Tesco does it on a more mass basis with
its with its individual consumers in its
supermarkets in the countries it
operates in so many of these comings
again ban began be by stressing
performance values so let's look at one
example of this Oregon orator is
actually was originally part of icid UK
company and one of the and it made
explosives for among other things
blasting and in rocks and quarries
historically I see I explore system made
better explosives than some of its
competitors where all the time it became
commodify
and a price game at that point
Oracle realized of course what its
customers want is not explosives what
they would like to have is rock on the
ground that meets their size
specifications a customer might only
want rock on the ground that perhaps
carries between half an inch in diameter
and six inches in diameter if it's too
much bigger than that it has to go
through as either a blasting the
secondary blasting operation or go
through a particular kind of crusher if
it's too small and maybe too small to
process it's not valuable to the
customer so what Erika did is the toko
it started to provide blasting services
for its customers so it offered to take
over the blasting activity from its
customers do the blasting in the
quarries and the mines most cases and we
begin with a three or six month trial
using the customers all equipment and
blasting crews if the trial is
successful or was successful or occur
and the customer would sign long term
contract and staff and the equipment
typically would become or occurs
responsibilities and a key thing was the
customers paid Orcutt for not for the
blasting but for the rock on the quarry
floor or the mine floor had met their
side specifications but certain numbers
of dollars per ton now of course when
Eric is doing these blasting solutions
it's doing it for quarries and mines
around the world
it's built some very very sophisticated
models to help it do the blasting so
this is so based on things like
temperature rock conditions obviously
the customer requirements in terms of
size and so on the blasting patterns
where it will put how much of the
explosives are will put in each kind in
each of the in each of the blasting
holes the timing the sequencing of the
plot of the glass and so on you can it's
been become much better at doing a blast
so more of the rock meets the size
specification of the customer with rust
wastage with less dust that's less needs
some secondary processing so
is done is created value the customers
are willing to pay for some of this
value created goes to the customer and
put of course a lot of it is kept by
Orica itself so now it's gone from the
commodity business of blasting
explosives to bases whether to a
business where there are huge barriers
to entry for a good enough competitor
trying to break into this market with
these very very sophisticated models it
has developed a core capability that
competitors have difficulty matching so
what we've seen today in our there are
three major options that companies have
for responding to low-cost or Goodenough
competitors one is to is to move into
the good enough space ourselves perhaps
staying also obviously and I will call
premium business the second one is just
to stay in the chemical performance
leadership game which is where most
companies typically start and then but
try to find a way to stay ahead of them
the competitors does SKF did or as we
already did offer this rock on ground
service which is what they call that
lasting service to customers from where
value and are willing to pay for a
company willing to create to provide
very integrated solutions and a service
for their customer so if we had to
summarize that more cost competition is
a big and growing challenge for many
leading companies and I'm sure than many
of you that are listening to this
webinar it won't go away and you have to
respond to it because what we've seen of
course there are customers including
many of you and either your business or
private lines you're looking for good
enough solutions that are attractively
priced this is pretty inedible
inevitable the products and services
become more and more commoditized over
time low cost competitors and thanks
emphasizing this price volume emerge to
service these markets all the time they
can threaten the premium brand and
market and you shouldn't be attempted
really to ignore the threat because a
few initial losses to the low-cost
competitors because as we talked about
last night last time with companies like
Huawei the momentum builds very very
rapidly and it become it can become
unstoppable
but what we thought about the day is you
do have options for how to respond to
the low-cost threat meeting the
challenge requires some very very tough
choices but the earlier companies make
the tough choices that better will be
that position in the long run so when
you talk to people that have passed this
challenge and try to deal with it
almost always when you say what would
you have done differently almost always
this the response is we should have
moved much much faster than we actually
did well thank you for listening maybe
we have time now for turn it back over
to Ryan and maybe we'll have time for a
few Q&A few questions how would you
compare Intel an apple where both have
distinct advantages for the high end and
struggling and are struggling to get
into the low end market how does the
global economy play into this view
that's a good question I mean I think
we'll maybe find out a bit today later
today when the Intel quarterly
announcement and conference call and so
on about Intel is obviously been
struggling a little bit against our
holdings and in the mobile space and so
we're seeing the company that they're
fairly successfully with the PC
processor with the Celeron helped help
certainly help it to compete against a
number of low-cost saw offerings in the
personal computer space helped it to get
into there and compete more effectively
in that segment of market against the
AMD and veer and so on yes it's
difficult when you look at both them
Apple and Intel they both have
challenges and Intel clearly has a lot
of technology going for it so that's an
area where there's still some
performance leadership
Unity's I think as it it shrinks lithium
the feature size on on its on its chips
and so on it has an opportunity through
through technology I think that competes
with all things in terms of power and
things like that Apple is a very
interesting one it's it's although it's
being preparing a performance leadership
gama argue that it also has preferred
being preparing for the day that
performance leadership advantage is gone
and by that i mean it's the things like
itunes the retail stores it's really
doing been doing a quite a good job of
building relational value with its with
its end-users so i think it is not just
dependent on products anymore it is
building some fairly tight and intimate
relationships with customers there will
be hard for little cost for example
chinese players to disrupt doesn't mean
they won't take a lot of share away from
apple but apple i think it's being doing
a pretty good job so far of
transitioning preparing for the day when
performant it's very difficult for it to
maintain a performance leadership
position thank you all right all right
I'm going to say thank you for everyone
who submitted a question we likely will
not have time to answer them all here
during the webinar hopefully we can get
you answers after our next question is
going to is how easy is it for a company
that is in playing a performance
leadership game to serve customers who
want good enough products at low prices
yeah that's that is a real a real
challenge and we've seen lots of
failures you know you can think about
all of the the European and North
American Airlines that have tried to
cheat to compete with the low-cost
competitors very unsuccessfully at this
point the issue is often it's not just
about the product or the packaging it's
about having a drum often a dramatically
lower cost structure fixed cost
structure in particular and I think
that's what Western come we see when
they go to China it's not so much the
variable
costs of these competitors they have
trouble dealing with its the
dramatically lower fixed cost structure
another day and part of that is also
often in may need a very different route
to market to meet to get to the good
enough customers in the market
particularly if the customers are for
example in developing markets like China
in India it may be getting away from the
cost from the tier 1 and T to our cities
in China getting to the tier 3 and T or
4 and the rural areas and so on so it
requires a very different go to Marx
credit market strategy then we have
typically adopted and this is a big big
challenge for in both b2b and b2c space
for companies doing it it's and as I
mentioned earlier it's a lot about
mindset let me just give you one quick
example of that
I mentioned the ABB example in process
automation with Wynn mission I won't go
into the whole story about building this
company from scratch but but one of the
things they did was they put its small
team together to build the company and
they got an old bicycle factory as their
first factory that needed obviously
totally RIA quipping as an office and
factory for Wynn mission and one of the
things they did of course was they they
got bits from some their traditional ABB
suppliers to refit the the offices in
the factory and so on and they got from
some more traditional Chinese players
and the Chinese bids were dramatically
lower than the ABB the traditional ABB
supplier and one of the interesting
things was just a just an example was
the carpet the carpet that the Chinese
supplier was offering had a three-year
life and the traditional ABB person the
company they would normally outfit their
offices was offering carpet with a 15 to
20 year life so the wind of the Chinese
supplier and said why are you offering
carpet with only a three-year life it
and the Chinese supplier said look if
you're successful you look vastly
outgrown this building in three years in
the building you'll be looking for a new
building three years is good enough if
you're not successful
you look close the business down and you
will need it anyway so three year life
is extra carpet is actually perfect for
you so that's what I mean about the
mindset it's very difficult to go from a
high performance leadership mindset to
to really think like a low-cost
competitor there are some good examples
of companies that have done it
successfully but it almost always needs
a separate business unit with a separate
management team and so on it's a huge
huge challenge so it's not about just
about physical product and so on it's
about the total mindset that one needs
after you write to write thank you so
much
well that actually brings us to the end
of our webinar if so hopefully we'll
have an opportunity to send some of the
questions that we had again in the queue
to Professor Ryan's and have an offer to
have hopefully an opportunity for him to
send you maybe a short answer of course
you're always welcome and encouraged
they come to the executive Institute and
talk to him personally at this time
again I want to thank the professor and
our attendees and this ends our webinar
today